captain marvel has started her descent
the trailer for the 21st century in the
marvel cinematic universe has arrived
with explosive style and we couldn't be
more excited
so suit yourself up in mohawk mode and
follow along as we break down all the
little details in the first trailer for
marvel's captain marvel
psyche magnet fragilistic expialidocious
did i say that right i don't even know
in the comics carol originally received
her powers by being caught in the blast
of an exploding psyche magnetron
whatever that actually is
at the time carroll was the head of
security on a u.s air force base
in the trailer carroll can be seen in an
air force jumpsuit
looking roughed up in the desert
potentially having just had her plane
shot out of the sky
soon after she's enveloped in some fancy
blue light an all-time classic giveaway
for made-up powerful comic book energy
is this the movie version of the
exploding psyche magnetron altering
carol's dna to give her powers after
crashing to the earth during a creed
scroll dogfight
maybe ronan we meet again the trailer
features a familiar silhouette for mcu
fans
sure looks like the return of ronan the
accuser back to life and captain marvel
through the magic of the prequel
this time the former guardians of the
galaxy bad guy technically should be on
the side of the good guys with carol
considering his status as a cree and the
kree empire
in the comics ronan attempted to
overthrow the kree empire bringing him
into conflict with marvel whether or not
that conflict will be repeated in this
movie remains to be seen
origin stories carol danvers isn't the
only origin story that captain marvel
movies appear to be remixing the movie
also seems to be ceding a whole new
origin story for another hero once known
by the name of captain marvel
the trailer shows a chummy relationship
with carol danvers and another air force
pilot by the name of rambo
most likely a reference to monica rambo
a marvel comics character who
technically was the first female captain
marvel
taking the name well before carol did
since carol first went by the super name
miss marvel
comics are weird all that said this is
not moniker but rather a younger version
of maria rambo monica's mother because
this movie is a prequel we may meet
maria's daughter monica at some point in
this film
or maybe in a future sequel or spin-off
there are some marvelous possibilities
scrolling crones everyone's gonna walk
away from this trailer talking about one
moment
but as you probably suspected that is
all how it seems we're pretty sure the
main bad guys of the movie will be the
scrolls an intergalactic warrior race
that once did battle with the cree
they've pestered marvel's superheroes
for years with their numerous attempts
to invade earth the scrolls appeared
just before the old lady in the trailer
implying a connection between the two as
you might have surmised the scrolls are
shapeshifters being in their basic forms
humanoid aliens with reptilian or
goblin-like qualities
so while their secret shape-shifting
scrolls already lurking in the marvel
cinematic universe
this movie sure seems to make that a
safe bet
target acquired captain marvel is
putting marbles to aging cgi to work to
spectacular effect on samuel jackson's
young by club dick nick fury
agent of shield from the looks of things
young fury will spend the first act of
the movie working to track carol danvers
down
after she bursts open the blockbuster
but will they be friends or foes
fury's pager has the answer as he sends
a message with target which is kind of
far off from with my new pal carol
we know from the end of infinity war
that the two end up at least as pen pals
but it will be interesting to see if
they face any opposition from each other
on their way to becoming best birds
big guns and green guys finally the
first captain marvel trailer also
features what appears to be a scene of
roswell-esque alien dissection
with what looks like a skrull's body
lying prone on an operating table
while a scrubbed abductor digs in and a
g-man looking gentleman looks on
also present in the shot nick fury
holding what appears to be from this
distance a purple space bazooka
and an ice pack on his eye the arrival
of the scrolls on earth in the 90s
raises a lot of questions about the mcu
of now the movie will certainly explore
their shape-shifting powers and the
eerie implication is that there could be
spies from another galaxy
all over the mcu we know how much do you
want to wager that the next big marvel
guessing game will be what heroes have
been secret scrolls this whole time